we have to talk about this figure and
this lady in this dress you look amazing
I got to stand back yes et's Michelle
Turner was with a spell to Oprah Winfrey
at the essence festival on Saturday in
New Orleans the media mogul opened up
about her weight-loss journey using
Weight Watchers to shed some serious lb0
was on hand to celebrate the new drama
series she co-created with Ava Duvernay
called Queen sugar premiering September
6th on own I have this idea for
inclusiveness let's do something that's
never been done before
let's give women badass their badass
directors already in their own right
there in the film directors and
producers but a lot of them haven't had
the opportunity in series television not
only is Oprah excited about her new show
she's also reflecting on her past this
September marks the 30-year anniversary
of the Oprah Winfrey Show
do you ever look back and say should I
have stayed dirty here
I never wanted to be the person who
didn't know when to exit the party room
it was the glorious most amazing
platform anybody can have to speak to
millions of people every day and I think
I exited at exact the right moment